vous écoutez la propre
glace de deux Compton à facile e et dr.  dre la était vraiment
dangereux dans les années 1980 les gangs la
police est ce baril de poudre qui a explosé et
NWA a écrit à ce sujet un
gars censé être quelque part nous devions l'
exprimer à un moment donné ce sont des artistes le
rap n'est pas un art vous ne pouvez pas venir
ici et  harceler mes clients à cause
de leur apparence
et cette musique nous a donné une voix ils
rapportaient ce qu'ils ont vu dans leurs
communautés ces jeunes hommes qui vous savez ont
essayé de défendre quelque chose qu'ils ne veulent pas
NWA
tuons-les en w-attendez ça  n'est-ce pas les
Crips and bloods c'est un glissement du
gouvernement fédéral sur W c'était vraiment
brut et nouveau cela a changé beaucoup de culture à
tous les niveaux ils ont été les pionniers des
rires modernes mmm 50 cents Snoop Dogg tout
cela vient de ce que nous avons fait  c'est bon pour toi
d'être toi-même et de le faire comme tu veux le
faire yo Dre quoi de neuf j'ai quelque chose à
dire comment tu vas de la vente de pierres dans la
maison de drogue pour dîner et une maison blanche